I want to give you my bulletproof coffee
hack now BOPE of coffee is used when
you're on keto and doing in a minute
fasting normally people take it in the
morning to allow them to go a longer
period of time without eating because it
has fat in it it's composed of coffee
grass-fed butter and MCT oil blended up
it tastes pretty good and this is
especially good to do when you start a
keto program because it allows you to go
a longer period of time without eating
and because it has MCT oil in it will
give you more ketones to make this
transition a little faster because
sometimes when you starting keto it
might take three to five days for your
body to start making more and more
ketones but if you're taking ketones
your brain will get them right away and
you have less of a transition phase as
in less keto fatigue or less brain fog
but the way that I do bulletproof coffee
is slightly different
I do the coffee in CT oil I do add one
packet of xylitol okay
and yes it's not zero on the glycemic
index it's thirty so it does influence
the blood sugars a little bit but
because I'm having such a small amount
it's really insignificant but here's the
hack I add chocolate to this coffee
mixture but not the chocolate that has
the sugar it is the unsweetened 100%
cacao type chocolate now here's the
thing because it's super concentrated I
only add a little square of this in the
coffee chop it up it melts right in
there because cacao enhances the
cognitive function it has cardio
vascular protection it helps your blood
sugars it's anti-inflammatory Innokin
increase your mood it also has something
called theobromine which is similar to
caffeine cacao also has a very small
amount of caffeine like 0.12 0.7% which
if we compare it to coffee coffee has
like 1.2 percent but this is like 0.12
0.7 percent now what is the difference
between cacao and cocoa let's talk about
that
okay cacao is less processed and has
more phytonutrients and has more
magnesium or iron and this additional
natural chemical called phenyl ethyl
amine which can improve focus and
attention anti-inflammatory properties
and polyphenols which is a phytonutrient
which can give you additional health
benefits so cacao is less processed and
cocoa is heated okay so it's more
processed we take a look at the fat in
cacao it's 11 grams okay cocoa powder
it's 3.5 grams protein 1 gram cocoa is
2.5 grams carbs 6 grams okay
cocoa powder is 16 grams now I'm talking
about one ounce so if we take a look at
this bar right here it's 2.3 ounces so
it would be basically we're talking
about a small section of this that's why
they're comparing this so if we're
talking about the amount of cacao that I
use which is like one section might be
one and a half to maybe 2 grams of carbs
so it's very very small and of course we
can't forget about the fiber three grams
versus nine grams right here and I do
recommend using a hundred percent cacao
however you can use other types of non
sugar chocolate as well like Lily's
brand this one is a forty percent cacao
and it's sweetened with a wreath root
all and stevia so for me I like the
additional cognitive and nutritional
benefits but realize if you do too much
it could affect your sleep at night
because of this stimulant and this
stimulant right here when you're adding
MCT oil or grass-fed butter it's great
to do in the beginning when you're doing
keto but if you're trying to lose weight
your body could be using these ketones
more than your own ketones that are
generated from your own fat burning so
in my case I want to get the ketones
from the dietary fat
more than I do from my own fat all right
so go ahead and try this out and tell me
if you like it good morning good morning
can you bring me a cup of coffee you
want your MCT oil and chocolate mm-hmm
do you want the MCT oil and chocolate